esse whatsappzinho que você manda
mensagem Tudo tranquilo meu amigo
antigamente não era nem mensagem era
torpedo e você tinha que comprar um
pacote com 25 torpedo por apenas r$ 15
era tranquilo demais mandar mensagem a
cara da pobreza era chegar no amigo sem
falar assim Eita torpedo se você acha
que no Twitter você abrevia as coisas
que você abrevia as coisas vc você acha
que abreviação vai ser ninguém escreveu
uma palavra não era só você ter tempo
era pataca Se eu ler sua mensagem
daquela hoje em dia eu pensava que era o
menino do ar que tava tentando contato
comigo a gente procurava o melhor meio
brasileira é brasileiro e a gente
descobriu que se a gente falasse só três
segundos não pagava a chamada cara
as conversas era assim imagina vou jogar
bola bora bora o cara responde mano aqui
olha agora só botar o chato aqui eu vou
levar rapidinho beleza rapidão só vou
comer um pouco dela aqui rapidinho eu
vou aí viu vocês se distrair se
demorasse mais de 3 segundos meu Deus do
céu Beleza pai rapidinho só vou tomar um
banho aqui tomar banho e vou lá para a
esquerda viu falou
cinco segundos